The Walking Dead has been a whirlwind
success for AMC and its continued high
ratings are proof that the recent zombie
pop-culture craze is more than a fad but
the show has not been without its fair
share of issues both on screen and off
here's the behind-the-scenes history of
The Walking Dead
you might not know beam me up Robbie
when comic book writer Robert Kirkman
first came up with his concept for The
Walking Dead he didn't want his idea to
fester in some pile of generic zombie
pitches so he added a little something
extra to the mix aliens yes aliens
Kirkman revealed that when he first
approached publisher Image Comics about
his story ideas they thought his story
could use an extra hook so he threw in
an otherworldly element suggesting that
his zombies could have been sent to
Earth by aliens
Kirkman never intended to follow through
with that plot track but it got him the
greenlight ultimately Kirkman did circle
back on the alien theme in issue number
75 which features a bonus ending that
had some fun with that original concept
artist fights back Tony Moore whose
artwork appeared in many early issues of
Kirkman's comic series filed suit
against the author his childhood friend
after he felt duped into signing over
his financial rights to the franchise he
claimed he was owed a significant slice
of the brainy pie once the series hit it
big Kirkman disagreed and filed a
countersuit against Moore alleging he'd
breached their confidentiality agreement
with his filing the two amicably settled
their dispute in 2012 and more returned
to draw a variant cover for The Walking
Dead issue number 150 paying tribute to
his cover of issue number 1 which
originally debuted back in 2003 an intro
to remember a lot of things have changed
over the years on The Walking Dead but
the one thing that's remained the same
is that spooky intro music that lulls us
into some undead submission every
episode
[Music]
composure Bear McCreary designed the
iconic score and yes he intended for it
to be just that dreary
in a 2010 interview with mtv news he
explained that he wanted to capture a
sense of emptiness with the string notes
of his opening number as it was the
feeling he got from watching it he said
quote I wanted to create something that
would get stuck in your head
so that when you hear it you would think
of the walking dead mission accomplished
showrunner switcheroo Frank Darabont was
the Walking Dead's first showrunner and
his fingerprints are still all over the
place not only did he recruit the
original cast some of whom he'd worked
with before but he built the world
foundation upon which the show still
stands with Robert Kirkman so it was a
complete shock to him and everyone else
when the network decided to give him the
boot in season 2 dare Bob pursued legal
action against AMC accusing the network
of creating crisis level problems by
slashing the show's budget in spite of
rating success and accusing executives
of essentially inventing reasons to fire
him as of the making of this video
Darabont is seeking more than two
hundred and eighty million dollars in
damages Jeffrey deMunn who started in a
ton of Darabont's movies including
Shawshank Redemption The Green Mile and
the missed loyally followed Darabont
through the exit sign soon after his
untimely departure pre Daryl Dixon
Norman Reedus is crossbow wielding hero
Daryl Dixon has emerged as one of the
show's fan favorite characters but
Reedus originally auditioned for the
part of Merle which had already gone to
Michael Rooker showrunners liked to read
us so much though they created the part
of Daryl specifically for him talk about
a happy accident
the jail scene the prison setting might
have been fictional but some of the
Walking Dead's cast members have found
themselves behind bars in real life for
their extracurricular activities in 2012
actor Scott Wilson who played old man
Herschel in the show was arrested for
drunk driving then in 2015
Seth Gilliam who plays the good Reverend
Gabriel was also arrested for DUI and
possession of marijuana Sheriff Rick
must have been off duty those nights
thanks Carol Steven Yeun was born in
Seoul South Korea so his parents have
something of a language barrier when it
comes to fully understanding what's
happening on the show apparently in a
moment of confusion they told him to
make sure and thank co-star Melissa
McBride for that time Carol saved
everyone from the cannibals even after
Yun tried to explain that everything
happening on the show is fictional his
father insisted he thank her so he did
he Road Dogg Dooley the dog who played
Daryl and Beth's one-eyed canine
companion in season four was a real-life
hero he lost his right eye while
defending his owner from a carjacker
bravest cast member ever yup zombie
makeup levels with so many zombified
extras that play in any given episode
the makeup department has had to be
choosy as to which members of its crowd
get the full workup
so execs devise three levels of zombies
the highest is hero which gets the
full-body makeover like this guy make
sure we salon the back of his head and
the shoulders are really well and then
there's mid ground which warrants some
facial transformation and costuming
and when there's a horde of zombies on
screen many of the undead extras further
away from the camera just wear a zombie
mask and some ragged clothing no matter
the level though every extra has to go
to zombie school before filming to learn
how to move like a true biter mmm
what is that what about you I do it my
chief teaching of the zombies oh it's
pretty
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to see more videos like
the one you just saw and let us know in
the comments which Walking Dead facts
surprised you the most